Bon d'accord j'ai été un peu cachottier je vous ai caché
un projet sur lequel je bosse depuis l'année dernière
Maintenant je vous en parle
Cet été, sur ma chaîne YouTube...
*son de suspense*
Je sors...
...Une série audio...
...Qui s'appelle...
..."L'épopée temporelle".
Voilà c'est dit.
Fallait que ça sorte à un moment...
Quoi? C'est quoi une série audio?
Alors, une série audio, c'est comme regarder une série...
...mais en fermant les yeux. Voilà. C'est... globalement.
Dans l'"Epopée temporelle", vous allez entendre des personnages
incarnés par des comédiens de doublage,
du bruitage, de la stéréo, de la musique composée spécialement pour l'occasion
Mais c'est surtout des personnages marrants,
Qui vont vivre une aventure incroyable
Du suspense, des méchants, bref: une grande aventure
Pour vous, cet été, sur ma chaîne YouTube. Toutes les semaines.
C'est dix épisodes de huit minutes environ qui racontent l'histoire de trois personnages:
Thomas, un jeune loser que j'incarne
Iris, une fille qui vient du futur
Et Elliott, un robot et ils vont traverser le temps à la recherche d'un grand scientifique
Ces personnages-là vont visiter plein d'époques:
L'égypte antique, la civilisation maya,
Ils vont même aller en Allemagne, pendant la seconde Guerre Mondiale, ils vont croiser des nazis.
Je vous en dis pas plus: no spoil.
J'ai écrit l'histoire avec Navo, François Descraques et Yacine Belhousse
J'avais une histoire un peu folle, et ils l'ont rendue encore plus dingue.
L'enregistrement, c'était mortel, avec Emmanuel Curtil, qui fait Jim Carrey
-Il se trouve que j'ai un chiffre après mon nom...
Patrick Borg qui fait SanGoku adulte,
Brigitte Lecordier qui fait SanGoku enfant...
-Nous acceptons votre défi!
-Haha! Il t'a grondé hier! J'étais là...
Véronique Augereau qui fait Marge Simpson
-C'est une mannequin ou un truc comme ça non? C'est quoi son prénom?
Des comédiens super, que j'adore, qui m'ont fait des personnages totalament barrés
Et je suis super content de ça, j'ai hâte que vous entendiez
-Un cappuccino! Combien de sucres?
-Le célébrissime pirate La Buse, [rire diabolique]
-Moi! Je le remplace!
Pour l'anecdote, j'avais déjà fait des sketchs audio en 2007 avec mon pote Jérémy
Ca s'appelait les "tripadeubal"
[voix modifiés] Salut dream, ça va ?
- Salut night, ouais ça va et toi ?
- ouais ouais, j'ai perdu mes parents, j'ai fais une fausse couche mais sinon ça va
Du coup de faire l'épopée temporelle, c'est un petit peu un retour aux sources pour moi,
revenir à des trucs que je faisais avant de me lancer sur youtube.
Et en bonus pour agrémenter la série audio, vous allez découvrir pendant chaque épisode
des dessins fais par des illustrateurs différents
qui vont interpréter des passages de l'histoire,
qui vont interpréter même les personnages. Donc vous allez voir par exemple
un personnage qui va avoir cette tête là, et juste après il aura cette tête là. C'est comme la couverture d'un livre,
elle est là mais c'est pas important, c'est l'histoire, libre cour à ton imagination !
Le premier épisode sort le jeudi ..
...sur ma chaîne youtube et ensuite ça sera tous les jeudis à la même heure sur ma chaîne
Et comme je suis très sympathique, un petit extrait, .. cadeau ;)
[MUSIQUE] A travers les époques, les dangers, une grande aventure les appelles
[MUSIQUE] C'est..... L'EPOPPEE TEMPORELLE
[VOIX OFF] Je le sens d'ici, tu te demandes sûrement
ce que tu es en train d'écouter,
cher auditeur.
Tu vas découvrir une aventure
débordante de rebondissements et de sauts dans le temps
Hop, hop, hop, hop c'est tout, pas plus, à non ! Il faut pas abuser des bonnes choses.
De toute façon si vous voulez découvrir la suite c'est très simple
... sur ma chaîne youtube pour le début de l'épopée temporelle
A écouter avec des écouteurs, par exemple
avec un casque, avec une enceinte, au bord de la plage, sur votre smartphone,
tout seul avec des amis, c'est comme vous voulez
Soyez au rendez-vous et pour ne rien louper, vous pouvez cliquer sur la petite cloche
comme ça vous êtes sur de recevoir la notification si vous êtes abonné
et si vous n'êtes pas déjà abonné, il faut cliquer ici
comme ça vous êtes sur de voir tous les épisodes de l'épopée temporelle.
J'attends que vous cliquiez sur les trucs, .. je reste là
une heure ou deux mais ... tu cliques, ça apparaît, wow
sur le téléphone, c'est un peu waouw
moi je trouve ça un peu waouw sur le téléphone...
(CHANTE) A travers les époques, les dangers, ...
... c'est ... l'épopée temporelle!
Je reste mais, clique hein !
(MUSIQUE ÉPIC)
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et a très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo ! #Jambon